next question is from Lorna Lorna says
if someone is telling you a story you've
already heard do you keep listening I
like this this is a good social
etiquette type question I know many
people who number one don't have the
best memory of what stories they've told
me and numbers you often don't care and
want to keep telling the story so
typically what I'll do I won't just
ignore the person although I I can
sometimes because I know the story I go
into autopilot mode I'm like yeah when
they stop talking I already know what to
say because they've told me the story
before sometimes though I will say oh
yeah yeah you've mentioned that before
and most people at that point will
interrupt the story and move on to
whatever point they wanted to illustrate
with the story most people I do know
people though that they just they want
to tell the story it doesn't matter
whether they've already told that
they'll say I don't know if I've
mentioned this to you before but when I
blah blah blah blah blah and I'll go oh
yeah you did tell me that they go yeah I
mean it was incredible because and then
they still tell me the entire story what
I'm sort of saying by telling you that
you told the story already is you don't
need to tell it again we can sort of
move on you know I do the exact same
thing I jump in i will recall some
aspect of the story and be like oh yeah
then this isn't this happened and kind
of involve my own take on it as well but
if someone else is telling a story where
another friend is involved and you heard
one take and now you want to hear
another take I love hearing to that oh
that is totally there everything is very
different because you want to hear their
perspective on it see what details get
changed who may have actually been at
fault of something that'll quite
entertaining that's a completely
different thing now if you're telling a
story and someone tells you that you've
already told it do you stop telling the
story yeah I mean you're in the image
control mode at that point you got to
move on I stop telling [ __ ] you could
make a different conclusion perhaps then
you would normally make definitely
change up the conversation at that point
is it rude to interrupt and say oh you
know you did mention this to me before
you're not saying shut up you told me
right i mean it you're saying oh this
actually you mentioned this story when
we were doing X Y Z I think it's rude i
think it would be even more strange if
the other person that's telling you a
story realizes at some point that
they're getting deja vu and that they've
told you this before
and that you just awkwardly didn't say
anything I think that would be more
strange oh that's interesting yeah later
they find out that you didn't tell them
that they actually had already told you
that story before you know I know people
who don't care they just want to hear
themselves tell the story they wouldn't
mind even if they knew that you told the
story that's not okay with it yeah so I
don't think there's anything rude with
interrupting in that way I do it all the
time I don't know why lots of people in
my life want to tell me the same stories
over and over again and I have no
problem interrupting in that way you've
told me this before is that true yeah I
think I haven't actually have I see now
i'm def nega metronome